America's Auto Workers are back to a
strange sterile new world employees at
Detroit's big three for General Motors
and Fiat Chrysler returned on Monday to
manufacturing plants where the new
normal is one part assembly line one
part hospital
there's 1977 and above this'll turn red
that'll turn red incoming workers
temperatures are checked so you're good
to go sir they work behind new barriers
with new masks gloves plastic face
shields and signs about social
distancing everywhere along with walking
lanes and reminders to stay six feet
apart assembly lines are restarting for
the first time since March when the
global pandemic shut down Detroit and
auto plants across the u.s. except for a
handful than made ventilators for the
sickest virus patients we see a little
grind to a halt so that's exactly what
happened one potential worry a global
supply chain that's been slowed by the
corona virus Mexico is still locked down
but last week the government unveiled a
plan that could see some auto parts
makers open to supply Detroit now that
automakers are building again the
question is in the worst market since
the Great Depression does anyone want to
buy the cars they're making across the
u.s. unsold cars by the thousands sit
idle delaying the introduction of new
models and in these belt-tightening
times competing with cheaper used car
dealers are offering once-in-a-lifetime
incentives like seven years of no
interest loans with little progress so
far
option and pay it cars a very big
purchase for a lot of people sometimes
purchase that may make so feeling
comfortable and say cannot buy a car we
take a while until buyers return enforce
the production lines will reopen more
slowly than they shut down and new cars
will keep aging on American car lots
John Hendren al-jazeera Chicago